Speaker 1: After weeks and weeks of making
strange, insensitive and ignorant comments
related to Jews and Judaism, radical Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green appears
to have had a I don't really want to call
it a come to Jesus moment because it relates
to the Holocaust.
Now, you might remember that Marjorie Taylor
Greene equated having to wear a mask on the
floor of the House of Representatives to how
the Jews were treated during the Holocaust.
And she said mandatory vaccinations are like
the Holocaust even there, even though there
are no mandatory vaccinations.
Then she doubled down on the analogy, but
later denied ever having made it.
But now Marjorie Taylor Green visited the
Holocaust Museum in Washington, D.C., and
then made a statement that, you know what,
she was wrong.
She apologizes.
The Holocaust was really very bad and there's
nothing comparable to it, presumably meaning
mask wearing is not like the Holocaust and
vaccinations are not like the Holocaust.
Check this out.
This is Marjorie Taylor Green.
Fresh off of the realization that the Holocaust
was really bad.
Speaker 2: I always want to remind everyone
I'm very much a normal person.
And I think it's important for me to always
be transparent and honest.
And I just want to tell you all I'm really,
really lucky.
I was blessed.
I am blessed with amazing parents.
And my dad passed away in April.
But I will say he taught me some great things.
And one of the best lessons that my father
always taught me was when you make a mistake
and I have made a mistake.
Really bothered me.
So I definitely want to own it.
This afternoon I visited the Holocaust Museum
Holocaust, and there's nothing where it happened.
Unidentified: You know, over six million Jewish
people were murdered.
More than that,
Speaker 2: there were not just Jewish people,
white people, Christians, all kinds of children,
people that that the Nazis didn't believe
were good enough and perfect enough.
And the horrors of the Holocaust are something
that some people don't even believe happened.
Some people deny, but there is no comparison
to the Holocaust.
Speaker 1: So Marjorie Taylor Green, they're
not only saying she was wrong for her Holocaust
comparisons, even calling out Holocaust deniers.
And we'll watch a little bit more where she
specifically says she said offensive things
and she apologizes for saying them.
Speaker 2: And there words that I have said,
remarks that I've made that I know are offensive.
And for that, I want to apologize to.
And I am I am just fine and very glad to be
able to come out here and do that.
I believe it's important.
I believe that if we're going to leave, we
need to be able to lead in a way where if
we've messed up, it's very important for us
to say we're sorry.
All right.
So listen,
Speaker 1: she does sound sincere in a way.
But it's also kind of a weird word, salad
with very little emotion, how if you really
didn't know how bad the Holocaust was, how
do you go through the Holocaust Museum, apparently
unaware of what you were in for, learning
about it for the first time, and you come
out of it with such a lack of emotion.
Now, whether the sincerity is coming from
her belief that the things she said are horrible
and offensive or the sincerity is coming from
her realizing that I've got to clean this
up because this this looks really bad for
me.
I don't know.
But she's doing something that lots of these
politicians never do, which is simply to say,
I was wrong.
Trump didn't say I was wrong.
I apologize once in four years.
So I give her credit for that.
But I don't really know that she didn't mean
it when she said it.
I think when she said that stuff about masks
and vaccinations on the Holocaust, I think
she did mean it.
And we're getting into evaluating what's in
her mind, and that's really tough.
But how does a 47 year old woman get to be
forty seven years old and not know how bad
the Holocaust was?
And this is what gives me the most pause.
Great.
She's owning up.
She's saying she was wrong.
She's apologizing that that's a great thing.
But how does a 47 year old American who, as
far as I know, went to school not realize
how bad the Holocaust was and think up until
age 47 that wearing a mask at Arby's is sort
of like the Holocaust in any way.
And then you learn you're wrong at age 47,
if you're really that ignorant, you have no
business being a member of Congress.
If you're not that ignorant and you're lying
to save yourself, you also have no business
being a member of Congress.
Don't most American children know by age 10
how bad the Holocaust was?
And if by age 10 you only had an idea by age
20, don't you really know how bad the Holocaust
was?
And even if at age 20 you skipped class on
that day by age 30, don't you understand it
totally and completely?
How do you arrive at age 47 with such little
idea about it that she thought masks were
sort of like the Holocaust until she visited
the Holocaust Museum?
Come on, guys, something about this stinks
to high heaven.
Let me know what you think.
I am curious to hear your thoughts.
What, if any, of this is
actually sincere?